je m'appelle Guy Carcasson je suis
professeur de droit public à
l'Université de Paris
[Musique]
disnan coucou ça
commence qui était gu Carcasson tour à
tour conseiller de mich on invité
régulier des plateaux télé et radio
expert auprès du Parlement français et
des gouvernements étrangers gu Carcasson
a eu 1000 vies mais une seule adresse et
un seul titre professeur de droit à
l'université de
nanter
nanter son unique por d'attache les
étudiants son ardente obligation la
transmission sa
passion nom thâre du bâtiment F n'est
pas inscrit dans nos
traditions c'est la première fois que
nous allons le faire l'idée c'est
pourtant rapidement imposé comme étant
une évidence pour tous et en particulier
pour les étudiants qui ont fait circuler
une pétition à cet effet l'idée même de
donner le nom de gu Carcasson à cette
hie a été magnifiquement entendu à tous
les niveaux de
l'université
Guy a eu 1000 occasions de répondre aux
sollicitations et aux sirènes d'autres
universités il ne l'a pourtant jamais
fait car son attachement à ses étudiants
à notre université était tout simplement
vicéral et évidemment on a proposé à Guy
quand il est devenu un grand prof
reconnu de venir àarien devenenir à
Paris de et il a toujours refusé et il a
toujours refusé parce que voilà c'était
je ne quitterai jamais
nanter nanter université drôle de
terminus pour gu
Carcasson personne dans sa famille n'a
jamais fait d'études et lui-même n'en
prend pas la voix puisqu'il est
régulièrement renvoyé du lycée pour
indiscipline mais voilà qu'en 1968 il
obtient son bac contre toute
attente je me suis retrouvé un beau jour
avec mon bac en poche bien embêté ENF
ravi évidemment mais mais néanmoins un
peu un peu perplexe du coup bah fallait
bien m'inscrire quelque part il était
trop tard pour essayer de s'inscrire à
sciencep donc je m'étais inscrit
enendroit et puis m'inscrivant en drroit
on m'avait dit bah chez vous pour vous
ça se passe à Dre bon je métais inscrit
à Dre et puis je m'étais retrouvé comme
ça en première année de fac en octobre
68 octobre 68 nanter il y avait pas de
ROR c'était le train par la verre
saint-lazar et à l'arrivée on avait
àranchir de cordons d'abord un cordon de
bidonville et ensuite un cordon de
gardeemobile et enfin on accédait au
bâtiment m 68 a commencé à Lanter et
donc mais 68 reste très agité mais rien
non plus de de terrible ça il y avait
les CRS qui venaient de temps en temps
parce que il y avait un peu d'agitation
oui il y avait une petite part de
folklore mais parfaitement margine
sa dans ces années on on avait la vie
belle c'était les années d'avant la
crise on ne connaissait pas encore le
chômage on ne se faisait pas de souci on
prenait on prenait son temps on vivait
agréablement j'étais déjà marié j'avais
de quoi vivre pas pas grassement enfin
j'ai perdu beaucoup beaucoup de temps
comme j'étais plutôt d'un naturel
paresseux et non chalant mes trois
premières années de droit ont été
essentiellement 3 années de bridge je
trouvais que le mélange entre le bridge
pour l'essentiel du temps et les tdé
pour une partie du temps
était som tout très agréable nousous
sommes rencontrés sur les bands de la
faculté comme on dit puisquon était
ensemble dans ce qui s'appelait un
DEA de droit public le 3e cycle qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui doctorat
à nanter et très vite on a eu les mêmes
intérêts
intellectuel le même goût pour les
blagues et on est devenu des amis qui ne
se sont plus jamais quittés et c'est
donc là que j'ai fait la connaissance
d'Olivier là pour le coup j'allais au
cours et pour cause quand les cours étai
donnés par Pierre avril Jean jquel René
de la Charrière bah évidemment ça
faisait des enseignements absolument
passionnant quand j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait deux étudiants particuliers dont
dont la présence dont les questions vous
interpellit et ces deux étudiants
c'étaaiit Guy Carcasson d'une part et
Olivier duamel d'autre part je
redoublais je redoublais de vigilance le
dialogue va être intense est-ce que je
vais être capable de répondre à toutes
les questions gu Carcasson il m apparu
dès cet instant comme quelqu'un qui
avait d'abord une facilité d'élocution
le sens de la répartie bref celui celui
qui allait devenir un bretur un bretur
redoutable Guy a eu le goût du droit et
du droit public pour la technique
l'art l'ingénierie il y a un rapport
entre jouer au bridge et résoudre un
problème de droit public il s'agit de
comment est-ce que je vais faire
l'impasse là pour arriver à cet objectif
bon normalement ça marche pas ouais mais
ah si je fais l'impasse
gu
adorit
trouver le trou d'aiguille le truc on
dit ah ça c'est pas possible ah oui mais
sauf si je retrouve ce décret là qui a
pas été utilisé qui contredit ça et et
là je vais y arriver et ça ça le
ça lui provoquait un immense plaisir et
comme c'était un épicurien un homme de
plaisir un
jouisseur je pense que le droit le
faisait parfois jouir en fait à partir
du moment où j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir commencer à enseigner tout
jointoyais de manière de manière
harmonieuse alors je faisais toujours en
même temps autre chose parce que je
gardais une fibre politique développée
j'étais devenu à temps partiel plus ou
moins conseiller juridique du groupe
soci liste à l'Assemblée mais tout ça
restait très cohérent avec avec
l'université et je me rends compte que
c'est ce que j'ai fait pratiquement
toute ma vie je dis toujours en
plaisantant que l'université prend une
fraction de de mon temps fait une
fraction essentielle de mon revenu mais
qu'elle fait 100 % de mon identité c'est
un grand avantage d'être au moins un
moment de sa vie un pied dans
l'université un pied dans la
politique pourquoi parce que dans
l'université vous faites un cor ctif
réel au cours
académique et
pourquoi dans la vie politique parce que
vous faites un correctif rappelons-nous
les principes à ce qui va être l'action
donc les deux il gagnent gu c'était un
animal aussi politique quand je dis ça
c'est absolument pas négatif il avait
comme on dit au foot une Vista des
intuitions des sensations puis surtout
surtout il aimait ça ce qui fait qu'il
devenait si bon ça fait des figures qui
qui qui sont un peu différente de celle
que qui connaî qui connaissent des des
parcours classiques de professeurs des
universités qui rejoignent leur
bandeuniversitaire lui cétait à la fois
aussi un homme d'action un homme proche
du pouvoir donc un conseiller du prince
bon ça ça ça transforme un peu les
choses le prince c'est Michel Rocard
Premier ministre socialiste de 1988 à
1981 auquel le professeur Carcasson
prête sa plume et son idéal de
démocratie je rêve tout simplement d'un
pays ambitieux dont tous les habitants
redécouvrent le sens du dialogue
pourquoi pas de la fête et de la liberté
une des contributions les plus célèbres
de Guy Carcasson c'est la circulaire que
prend Michel Rocard lorsqu'il devient
premier ministre adressé à ses ministres
sur la bonne façon de gouverner à 99 %
cette circulaire est écrite par
guarcasson de A à Z orors si vous la
relisez bien elle prend évidemment en
compte la réalité de la bonne façon de
faire efficace mais elle rattache ça à
des principes ce code de bonne pratique
à l'usage des ministres pose deux
principes directeurs respecter la
Constitution et respecter le Parlement
bien travailler un projet de loi
s'assurer de sa constitutionnalité
laisser au parlementaire le temps d'en
débattre ce mélange d'idéalisme et de
pragmatisme Michel rckard et gu
Carcasson l'avaient en partage c deuxà
étaient fait pour
s'entendre pendant 7 ou 8 ans l'un de
mes plus proches et de mes plus
influents
collaborateurs mais c'était surtout et
il est resté bien plus longtemps bien
plus longtemps l'un des plus intimes de
mes amis c'est l'histoire d'une passion
Guy Carcasson et Michel Rocard
évidemment il y a une adhésion
intellectuelle il y a une adhésion
politique bien sûr qu'il y a tout ça
mais il y a aussi une passion pour
l'homme lui-même et le lien sera
d'ffecti se trouver à Matignon c'est
avoir la chance de se trouver
véritablement au cœur de l'État là où il
palpite en permanence je me vois encore
avec Rocard dans son bureau lorsque sont
tombé les estimations des législatives
de juin 88 comme quoi on allait avoir
qu'une majorité relative il y avait un
membre du cabinet qui a tout de suite
éclaté de rire en disant Carcasson
jackpot parce qu'il avait tout de suite
compris que la la majorité relative
évidemment allit donner un relief
particulier aux Relations avec le
Parlement puisque il n'y aurait plus
rien
d'automatique l'homme chotant à Michel
Rocard n'est pas un député c'est un
conseiller du Premier ministre Guy
Carcasson connaît ses parlementaires sur
le bout des doigts et c'est lui qui
informe minute par minute le chef du
gouvernement sur les intentions de vote
tâche essentielle car à 2h du scrutin
Michel Rocard est seul contre tous et
aujourd'hui plus que la CSG c'est sur sa
politique qu'il était attaqué
si on veut donner un exemple d'une
formidable réussite du politique de Guy
Carcasson
en
1991 c'est l'instauration de la
CSG et les socialistes n'ont pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale la CSG
fort loin de ressembler à l'épouvantable
caricature que vous en faites
elle est mesure de justice sociale de
solidarité et elle apporte dans le
fonctionnement de la sécurité sociale un
peu plus de démocratie par la
délibération annuelle de cette assemblée
sur une partie des
ressources texte par texte Guy Carcasson
a réussi à fabriquer des majorités
majorité stéréo quand à droite et à
gauche on les oppositions soutenaient
quand même majorité alliée sur la droite
majorité alliée sur la gauche mais là
c'est cuit parce qu'il y a une motion de
censure qui est déposée et tous les
groupes ont dit qu'ils allaient la voter
l'URE de vérité pour Michel Rocard le
sort du Premier ministre et de son
gouvernement se joue tout à l'heure lors
du vote sur la motion de censure déposée
par les trois groupes de l'opposition je
vous rappelle que le Parti communiste
votera lui aussi la censure et le
gouvernement ne tombe
pas parce que dans chaque groupe dans
chaque groupe il va manquer une de ou
trois voix et ce
travail de couture pour en gagner un
ici c'estasson qui l'a fait Michel
recard est donc sorti vainqueur de
l'épreuve de la censure hier soir la
motion n'a recueilli que 284 voix alors
qu'il en fallait 289 pour qu'elle soit
adoptée et voilà à 5 voix près Michel
rard sauve son siège et ce n'est pas
vraiment un miracle il a manqué C voix
et ces C voix l'opposition les digère
plutôt mal l'opposition accuse
clairement l'entourage de Michel Rocard
et notamment le dénommé gu Carcasson
conseiller du Premier ministre d'avoir
fait amicalement pression sur eux si il
est un certain nombre de choses que
l'expérience
enseigne lorsque l'on doit faire passer
des textes
difficiles lorsque l'on a besoin d'une
majorité
qualifiée lorsqu'il faut fabriquer un
minimum de
consensus et donc passer un maximum de
compromis il y a des méthodes
éprouvées nouer le
dialogue
avec les
interlocuteurs et ne pas les laisser
partir dans des fantasmes mais il lui
est arrivé aussi comme à tout le
monde d'être moins bon
conseiller est-ce que c'était une bonne
idée que Michel Rocard soit tête de
liste aux élections européennes de
non il s'est pris une liste àis contre
lui il na'a fait que 15 % et ça a
été la fin de ses espérances
présidentielles les Français viennent de
nous dire clairement que nous n'avions
pas parlé assez fort qu'il ne nous
sentait pas assez proche deeux j'en
prends acte pourquoi ser retiril de
toute ambition présidentielle faut vous
faire un dessin non non mais j'ai je
pose la question le plus naïvement du
monde en espant une réponse sera pas je
comprends bien mais si mais si vous
posez une question naïve ce sera une
réponse naïve il se retire de la
compétition présidentielle d'après ce
que j'ai compris et avec moi quelques
millions de Français tout simplement
parce qu'il n'a plus aucune chance de la
gagner est-ce que ça veut dire que sa
vie politique est terminée mais pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout on peut
faire des tas de choses extrêmement
utiles en politique et à son pays sans
être président de la République on peut
même on peut même réussir sa vie voir
être heureux sans être président de la
République et finalement gu était pas
très comment dire c'était un
artiste du
Parlement c'était un homme assez
compétent sur la
communication mais sur la vie
strictement électorale et interne au
parti socialiste c'était probablement
moins sa tasse de thé j'ai arrêté de
faire de la politique le jour où la
candidature de rard s'est cassé la
figure aux européennes en 94 en plus
j'avais fait mes preuves j'étais nul et
depuis je ne fais plus du tout de de
politique active je pas passé ma vie à
faire de la politique j'ai beaucoup
d'autres choses ça me passionne
évidemment mais j'ai aussi beaucoup
d'autres choses qui m'intéressent j'ai
cette chance donc voilà je fais autre
chose il est de
gauche il est prof de droit il est né en
1951 toute l'idéologie de la gauche
depuis la nuit des temps mais qui se
perpétue dans les années 60
70 c'est l'idéologie
parlementaire président de la République
fort c'est néfaste tout le pouvoir doit
venir et s'exercer au Parlement Guy
adore le Parlement Guy croit à
l'importance du Parlement et à ses
droits mais il pense que ce qui compte
c'est que quand le peuple vote il y ait
une majorité qui puisse exercer le
pouvoir pendant idéalement 5 ans et qui
est jugé à l'échéance et que chez nous
en France c'est passé par l'élection
présidentielle et la 5e République
autrement dit pour une fois on a une
démocratie qui permet au peuple de
choisir et au pouvoir de s'exercer et
pour cette raison il défend la 5e
République il avait mis sa maîtrise du
droit au service de la politique il
mettra désormais son expérience de la
politique au service du
droit Guy Carcasson devient l'un des
experts reconnus de la 5e République et
de sa constitution persuadé que ce mode
d'emploi de la démocratie qui s'applique
à tous doit être compris par tous
liardcasson a participé vraiment la de
la formation de cette culture
constitutionnelle euh évidemment à
l'intention de ses étudiants mais aussi
à l'intention du grand public c'était
sans doute le constitutionnaliste le
plus médiatisé et je pense que grâce à
ses interventions très fréquentes dans
les médias grâce à cet art de la formule
qu'il cultivait et bien il permettait au
plus grand nombre de comprendre les
grands enjeux du droit constitutionnel
et de la vie politique
il a écrit plus de 400 articles il a
collaboré à un numéro sur C de la revue
pouvoir et je crois qu'il a écrit 27
fois dans la revue pouvoir aucun n'a
écrit autant que lui il écrivait
formidablement bien mais il ne voulait
pas écrire de
livres je pense qu'il y avait une espèce
de lucidité sur l'article qui est le
lendemain ou sur lendemain chez le
poissonnier
mais le livre ça reste c'est dans une
bibliothèque ça peut être trouvé 10 20
30 100 ans après et là ça
l'arrêter je pourrais certes vous parler
de la révision mais enfin les palinodis
des uns et des autres font que le sujet
ne me paraît pas encore tout à fait mû
faut laisser dégorger les
escargots en conséquence de quoi je vous
propose une commémoration il y a 50 ans
jour pour jour de Gaulle revient à Paris
et convoque une conférence de presse il
explique combien il a combattu la
constitution de la 4e République s'il
revient c'est pour remettre la France en
route selon lui ce qui d'abord et avant
tout suppose l'adoption d'une nouvelle
constitution alors un jour je l' piégé
je lu dis j'ai une idée mais c'est pas
un livre bon si c'est pas un livre
peut-être c'est quoi oui tu écrives
quelque chose qui n'est pas un livre
mais quoi alors un commentaire de la
Constitution
ah oui ça ça peut être amusant une fois
qu'il a dit amusant je savais que
j'avais gagné la partie et vous verrez
que c'est un feuilleton assez
trépidant et qui a eu sur l'histoire de
notre pays une influence que je n'ai pas
besoin de souligner et il a écrit ce qui
est devenu un livre qui en est
maintenant à sa 14e 15e édition qui est
vendu à des milliers dizaines de
milliers d'exemplaires et chaque 2 ans
quand il ou chaque année ou chaque 2 ans
quand il fallait faire une nouvelle
édition rien ne lui importait plus il
avait pris des notes alors là pour le
coup c'était pas sur un coin de table en
passant constitu ses dossiers il
travaillait ligne à ligne à ligne et
finalement il a adoré son livre qui est
un livre de référence qui continue grâce
à Marc Guillaume pour être à jour alors
queil voulait pas écrire de livre chacun
était sûr d'y trouver dedans à la fois
l'apport du praticien et l'apport du
professeur de droit qui essaya de penser
la cohérence des institutions donc c'est
pour ça que ce livre a toujours
rencontré ce succès c'est que les les
gens il trouvaient une somme
d'informations venant de différents
points de vue alors quand il était
certain qu'il le ferait ce livre
euh j'ai appelé Claire Bretécher qui
était sa compagne en disant voilà on va
publier enfin un livre de Guy est-ce que
tu nous ferais un dessin pour la
couverture il cherche l'équilibre le coq
l'équilibre constitutionnel c'est
délicat parce qu'avant la 5e République
on a changé souvent de constitution on
l'a pas trouvé et comme Guy le montre
dans son avant-propos il pense qu'avec
la 5e République la France a trouvé à la
fois des institutions efficaces et une
démocratie il dit à certains endroits
qu'elle est perfectible mais c'est ça
qu'il a voulu démontrer défendre la 5e
République c'est tout chose après il
faut quand même l'améliorer
guyarcasson a mené beaucoup de combat à
participer au comité baladure à écrire à
influencer mais il y a deux grandes
choses qui viennent assez largement de
lui le la limitation le non cumule des
mandats on peut pas être en même temps
député et maire d'une grande ville on
peut pas être en même temps député ou
sénateur et président de Région
euh et ça c'est un combat qui a été
gagné jusqu'ici c'est
simple c'est simple et le deè c'est
celui qui se résume par une formule
mystérieuse QPC alors là c'est une autre
paire de manche c'est autrement plus
compliqué autrement plus technique et je
Seris tenté de dire autrement plus
important la QPC c'est
quoi c'est le fait que on doit donner à
à chaque citoyen en vérité à chaque
justiciable à chaque personne qui se
trouve impliquée d'une façon ou d'une
autre dans un procès dans un contentieux
juridique le droit de
contester une loi de contester une loi
qui violerait des libertés ou des droits
garantis par la Constitution l'idée est
purement et simplement
insupportable de se dire que on peut se
faire appliquer une loi qui est
contraire à la Constitution la QPC est
sans doute né à la la fin des années 80
quand le président
baninterre échangeant avec Olivier
duamel gu Carcasson Bruno genénvois et
d'autres c'est dit que il fallait
ajouter au contrôle à priori une forme
de contrôle à postériori en France pour
que les citoyens
puissent dans les procès qu'ils
intentaient soulever la possible
inconstitionnalité du texte législatif
qui leur été appliqué je vais passer la
parole à Maître Molin avocat au barreau
de Lyon et je vous prie de rejoindre la
barre la liberté monsieur le Président
Madame Monsieur du Conseil la liberté
individuelle la liberté d'aller et venir
la liberté qui fait partie de notre
devise
républicaine la liberté liberté chérie
qui combat avec ses défenseurs
elle est foulée au pied parce que cet
article 63 n'apporte aucune garantie au
stade du placement en garde à vue
concrète est-il nécessaire dans la
recherche de la vérité de garder une
personne dans des jaules sales au mépris
de son hygiène de lui interdire de se
laver pendant plusieurs jours est-ce que
cela participe de la recherche de la
vérité pas du tout est-ce que l'avocat
est nuisible à la recherche de la vérité
pas du tout il n'y a et il n'y aura
jamais qu'une seule garantie qui permet
de mettre un terme à tous les abus et à
tous les soupçons la présence de
l'avocat lors de l'interrogatoire de la
personne gardée à vue monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
membres du conseil constitutionnel je
vous demande de prononcer
l'inconstitutionnalité de l'article 634
alignéa 1 à 6 du code de procédure
pénale la France pays des droits de
l'homme ne doit pas craindre une avancée
des libertés je vous
remercie la Constitution était sûrement
un objet un peu lointain un objet
institutionnel un objet réservé au
politiqu et comme a bien dit à l'époque
Guy est devenu le bien de tout le monde
un bien indivie qu'on pouvait partager
pour essayer de de mieux vivre
collectivement
ensemble
et je vois aujourd'hui le nombre de
livres qui sortent sur la QPC sur le
Conseil constitutionnel je vois le
nombre de facultés qui organiseent des
rencontres des coloes je vois les
professeurs les étudiants qui viennent
rontpensciier pour essayer d'appréhender
cette révolution c'est un combat qui a
duré 30 ans et finalement qui a été
gagné en 2008 et qui a très profondément
changer les choses et y compris dans la
vie des gens parce que on a le droit à
un avocat dans une garde à vue parce que
les Français d'Afrique du Nord qui avait
pas le droit aux pensions auquel avait
droit les Français du continent alors
qu'ils avaient été dans l'armée faire le
même travail que tout d'un coup on
recouvert ses droits et cetera et
cetera donc il a mené et réussi ses
grandes batailles pour cette 5e
République qu'il défendait néanmoins
l'amander pour qu'elle progresse en ce
60e anniversaire de notre Constitution
c'est un grand professeur de droit que
je voudrais citer le regrettter D
cartasson qui s'exprimait
ainsi une bonne constitution ne peut
suffire à faire le bonheur d'une nation
mais une mauvaise peut suffire à faire
son malheur je pense que nous sommes
très nombreux à partager ce jugement
sage
il n'y a que deux personnes qui ont une
salle à leur nom dans ce bâtiment c'est
le doyen Vedel et SIG Carcasson et c'est
significatif de de l'idée
que les membres de cette maison
ressentaient gu Carcasson comme l'un des
leurs considéré comme un membre
officieux du Conseil constitutionnel il
a le souci de la bonne mesure en matière
de révision la Constitution n'est pas un
texte sacré figé dans le marbre elle
doit évoluer avec son temps pour autant
elle ne saurait être amendée à tort et à
travers au gré de l'actualité et des
commodités politiques il faut pas avoir
une position dogmatique sur la
constitution c'est très bien qu'elle
évolue mais simplement on ne doit pas
selon moi la faire évoluer par simple
commodité on veut faire quelque chose il
y a un obstacle constitutionnel on
modifie la Constitution non il faut y
réfléchir quand même à deux fois
convient de garder la tête froide même
quand les enjeux sont brûlants en Corse
une majorité des élus s'est mise
d'accord sur un constat pas de réforme
adaptée au besoins de l'île sans
révision de la
Constitution fiscalité foncier
enseignement de la langue corse toutes
les mesures butent sur cet
obstacle dès le début des années 2000
Guy Carcasson est sollicité par les élus
insulaires pour les aider à le
surmonter un professeur aussi
universellement reconnu une audience
nationale et internationale veuille bien
venir bénévolement
d'ailleurs organiser avec nous un
colloque dans le petit conseil général
de Haute Corse sur un sujet difficile
complexe montre qu'à ce moment-là déjà
Guy
Carcasson considérait la Corse et ces
questions comme important éclairer les
enjeux expliquer et rassurer si beso
l'objectif du collocque la Corse en
devenir organisé lundi dernier à Bastia
par le Conseil Général de Haute Corse la
question essentielle mais qui demeure
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui hein était de
savoir comment l'on pouvait rendre
effective des compétences juridiques
pour l'assemblée de cors qui lui
permettrait d'adapter un certain nombre
de règles aux spécificités de l'île vive
la révision constitutionnelle il a une
condition
c'est qu'on ne révise pas la
Constitution pour se faire plaisir on
révise la Constitution parce qu'il y a
des problèmes constitutionnels sur la
solutions desquelles on s'est accordé et
dont on constate qu'il passe par une
révision ça n'a rien à voir au risque de
refroidir son auditoire gu Carcasson a
renvoyé les élus à leur responsabilité
politique il ne sert à rien de réclamer
une révision constitutionnelle tant que
les revendications des uns et des autres
sont si
divergentes la parole de de
l'universitaire peut-être un élément
d'objectivation d'un débat qui est
d'abord politique la règle de droit
permet aussi
d'arbitrer et d'arbitrer sans qu'il y
ait ni vainqueur ni vaincu mais le
meilleur équilibre possible entre des
arguments contraires et il tenait
beaucoup à ce que les professeurs de
droit puissent répondre justement à ces
sollicitation il fallait pour gu que
nous tenions notre
rang à l'université comme dans ses
missions de juris consulte le style gu
Carcasson fait école d'autant qu'il
n'hésite jamais à chaque fois que
l'occasion se présente à faire équipe
avec des plus jeunes que
lui s'agissant de l'inscription de la
Corse dans la Constitution c'est sans
doute le symbole qui est recherché mais
la question qui devrait se poser c'est
celle de
l'efficacité on ne doit mentionner la
Corse dans le texte de la Constitution
que dans la mesure où cette inscription
ou cet ancrage constitutionnel
permettrait d'accorder à la collectivité
territoriale de Corse de nouvelles
compétences qui soi réellement effective
je dis pas que les les anciens auquel
j'appartient désormais joue un peu comme
nos nos grands maîtres d'avant 68 mais à
chaque fois qu' qu'on nous demande un
nom qu'IE bon on pense on pense à des
plus jeunes que soit et c'est mettre
mettre le pied à l'étrier et et ainsi de
suite il était très attentif à
accompagner à orienter à guider à aider
la jeune
génération et il a fait partie de ceux
qui pour moi ont ont éclairé le chemin
sans tracer la
route je pense qu'il fait partie des
professeurs qui m'ont permis de me dire
c'est vraiment ça que je veux faire la
fac c'est un peu effrayant quand on du
lycée d'arriver dans des si grandes en
filles avec tant de monde je pense que
ça fait partie des personnes grâce
auxquelles je me suis dit je suis pas
arrivée au mauvais
endroit il avait parfaitement conscience
desultés auxquelles sont exposés les
étudiants de première année non pas
qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'exigence pour eux bien au contraire il
avait une très forte estime de ses
étudiants mais il considérait qu'il
fallait les accompagner être gentil lui
qui pouvait être sévère et même féroce
quelquefois euh avec euh les adultes pas
avec les jeunes étudiants c'est vrai que
le public de première année est très
hétérogène vous avez une partie de ce
public-l qui va probablement arrêté dans
les premières semaines premiers mois
donc c'est un public difficile du coup
mais en même temps c'est un public
exceptionnel parce que c'est dans ce
public là que l'on décè les premiers
intérêts que l'on va susciter les
premiers intérêts
comme Guy Carcassonne c'est de très loin
mon cours favori mon maître oui favoreux
c'était la même chose jusquà sa mort il
garde le le cours d'enfi première année
et ça pour moi c'est le signe de ceux
qui vraiment sont passionnés par leur
discipline et par les étudiants ce n'est
pas vrai tous les professeurs he
certains se dérobent parce qu' un cours
magistral de première année ce sont des
amphill surchargé ce sont autant de
copies à corriger c'est une équipe de
chargé de travaux dirigés à animer donc
c'est beaucoup de travail euh mais Guy
faisait partie de ces professeurs qui
considéraient que c'était le cours le
plus important et peut-être avait-il
compris que que qu'il allait créer des
qu' qu'il allait susciter des vocations
c'est là que vous devez faire la part
des choses entre l'argumentation
juridique et les principes juridiques ça
m'arrive souvent de penser à lui quand
je fais cours je pense toujours à ce qui
me disait tout le temps à savoir queah
quand on veut communiquer à des
étudiants il faut les
le plus
possible c'est un rappel à l'ordre dit
Carcasson lorsque je fais un mauvais
cours et que j'en prends conscience
parce que des étudiants viennent
demander des explications
complémentaires je me rends compte que
précisément la démonstration n'était pas
suffisamment explicite c'est un rappel à
l'ordre être entièrement à mes étudiants
pendant mon cours et leur transmettre ce
savoir avec passion et la fantaisie
l'audace quand elle est associé à la
rigueur
scientifique ça je ne connais personne
que lui qui avait cette qualité là
pourquoi c'est important droit
constitutionnel pourquoi on en parle
ensemble aujourd'hui pourquoi selon vous
c'est une actualité qui nous intéresse
dans un
constitutionnel je vous proposerai à
chaque fois un ou plusieurs
thèmes que l'actualité me paraît imposé
étant entendu évidemment que chacun
d'entre vous pourra à tout moment soit
proposer des thèmes supplémentaires dès
lors du moins que je ne sois pas
radicalement
incompétent soit en tout état de cause
m'interrompre à tout instant pour poser
les question que vous voudriez persuadé
que son cours n'en sera que meilleur
l'actualité il ne cesse d'y participer
parfois loin de Nan terre en Afghanistan
après la chute du régime taliban au
début des années 2000 le gouvernement de
transition sollicite son expertise
constitutionnelle lucide sur les
difficultés qu' attendent il répond
néanmo à l'appel en infatigable militant
de la démocratie ils viennent d'arriver
à Kabou placé sous haute protection 500
représentants des multiples tribus
afghanes réunis pour une dizaine de
jours ils vont devoir se mettre d'accord
et aboutir à la rédaction d'une nouvelle
constitution pour leur pays vous avez
travaillé il y a quelques années sur une
mission de conseil pour la Constitution
afghane est-ce qu'il y a dans la
Constitution afghane aujourd'hui des
principes qui s'app
à l'égalité homme-femme euh le le
principe d'égalité est affirmé
évidemment il y a beaucoup de choses
bonnes affirmé dans cette Constitution
il y a moins de choses bonnes respecté
dans cette constitution c'est très terf
difficile d'être un bon conseiller
étranger dans la fabrication d'une
constitution beaucoup de nos collègues
vont simplement avec la constitution de
la 5e République et dit voilà ce qu'il
faut faire ce qui est absurde c'est
absurde il y a pas une constitution
idéale qu'on peut appliquer partout
constitution adapté à un d'une part
l'histoire et à la géographie d'un pays
et d'autre part au moment historique
dans lequel se trouve le pays il était
très attentif à la culture à
l'environnement politique juridique
social des des pays dans lesquels les
règles avaient vocation à s'appliquer il
faut une forme de technicité et humilité
et je pense que Guard Casson avait ça
comment naissent des constitutions
comment naissent des démocratie y a-t-il
des manières des méthodes appropriées
reproductibles selon
lesquels se fabrique une démocratie donc
je trouve que c'est toujours un miracle
de voir naître une démocratie voilà
c'était tout à fait passionnant le
miracle de la démocratie qui n'a
rigoureusement rien de naturel c'est
quand même la création la plus
artificielle que l'homme a jamais faite
ce qui est tout à fait naturel en cas de
désaccord c'est de taper sur son
voisin arriver à faire l'effort sur
soi-même de débattre de discuter
finalement de voter et de continuer à
débattre et à discuter c'est atteindre
un très haut degré de de civilisation
donc ce miracle démocratique il suppose
toujours que les citoyens n'oublient
jamais qu'ils le sont et que de seuls de
seuls peuvent venir les améliorations et
si l'on considère que l'on est pas
suffisamment entendu c'est généralement
parce que l'on n pas suffisamment
audible c'est généralement parce que
l'on est pas suffisamment nombreux c'est
généralement parce que l'on n pas
suffisamment convaincu donc n'oublions
jamais d'abord et avant tout que la
démocratie elle est notre bien commun et
elle deviendra toujours ce que nous et
nous seuls en ferons ces manifestants
réclamaient un référendum sur la
retraite à 60 ans en 20 ces faucheurs
volontaire auraiit voulu être consulté
sur les OGM tout comme ces
pétitionnaires sur la privatisation de
La Poste
impossible jusqu'ici car seul le chef de
l'État pouvait organiser un référendum à
l'avenir députés et citoyens pourront
ensemble demander une consultation c'est
une avancée précisément en ceci que
demain si véritablement un sujet
mobilise suffisamment les Français alors
il pourrait y avoir un référendum alors
qu'aujourd'hui même s'il y avait 20 30
40 80% des Français qui souhaitaent un
référendum ce ne serait pas possible si
le président de la République n'en
décide pas concernant le référendum
d'initiative minoritaire ou d'initiative
populaire je crois que cette idée qui
est assez ancienne qui fonctionne à
condition d'être
entouré de garantiese solide mais c'est
le cas dans la proposition qui est faite
dans un certain nombre de pays est une
idée juste est une idée féconde c'est un
véritable pouvoir nouveau donné aux
Français et je ne vois véritablement pas
pourquoi l'on devrait expliquer au
français que finalement ils sont en
quelque sorte mineurs pas suffisamment
adultes pour savoir ce qui peut mériter
leur consultation directe et donc ne pas
leur reconnaître ce pouvoir il ne s'agit
pas de quelque chose qui pourra se faire
tous les trois matins où les Français
sont motivés pour convoquer un tel
référendum et il est juste qu'il a lieu
ou ils ne le sont pas et il est juste
qu'il n''est pas lieu régulièrement
consulté par les parlementaires sur les
lois en débat Guy Carcasson s'efforce de
déconstruire les idées reçues et
d'encourager une législation raisonnée
l'exercice n'est pas très différent d'un
cours magistral il faut parler en
pédagogue et stimuler le sens critique
de son
auditoire la deuxième réforme annoncée
par Nicolas Sarkozi est une réforme
qu'il présente comme étant celle du bon
sens au bout de 10 ans on est usé donc
il faut limiter à deux le nombre des
mandats que peut faire un président de
la République l'article
intempestif c'est celui qui concerne la
limitation à de mandats pour le
président de la République je suis
désolé je sais que j'ai une opinion
hélas souvent minoritaire mais je
considère cela comme
insupportable si cette réforme est
adoptée je vous promets de ne pas sauter
par la fenêtre ça ne m'empêchera pas
complètement de dormir mais je la trouve
quand même stupide c'est c'est très
gênant parce que quand même cette manie
qu'a à mon avis un peu trop
fréquemment l'État aujourd'hui le
législateur en particulier de vouloir
protéger contre eux- même des adultes
consentant se fait toujours au détriment
de la liberté et lorsqu'en l'occurrence
il s'agit du suffrage universel lui-même
je trouve ça profondément
choquant même si il étaiit très content
d'un président qui a déjà fait deux
quinquen et ben tant pis les Français
n'auraient pas le droit de le rélire une
troisième
fois si les Français ont envie de
lesélire une troisème fois c'est à leurs
risques et périls au bout du compte si
j'ose dire ce sont eux qui trinquent
alors au moins qu'on les laisse librees
de leur choix accessoirement je
considère également cela comme dangereux
l'avenir est susceptible il n'aime pas
qu'on l'insulte on ne sait pas ce qui
peut se passer et oui il y a des moments
contrairement à à une idée reçue où il y
a des gens irremplaçables il suffit de
rappeler ce qu' était la situation du
monde si Roosevelt n'avait pas été
réligible en 1940 Franklin rosevelt
avait été élu en 32 il a été réélu en 36
donc 1940 c'était déjà son 3e mandat
alors je sais bien que ce type de
situation est très exceptionnel mais je
crois que vous me considéerez également
qu'il est très exceptionnel aussi qu'un
président puisse se trouver en situation
d'être réélu une troisième fois mais si
d'aventure un jour un président l'était
bah peut-être que ce serait tout
simplement devant le constat que c'est
le meilleur choix disponible alors s'il
s'agit simplement pour un président de
la République éventuellement l'actuel de
montrer qu'il n'est pas accroché au
pouvoir bon c'est très bien mais il a
d'autres moyen de le démontrer par
exemple en ne se présentant pas une
troisième fois ni même éventuellement
une deuxième il ne me paraît pas
indispensable
rig in et dangereuse dans lation à é
nicolasar n'entendra pas cet
avertissement et la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 limitera à 2
le nombre de mandats consécutif que peut
exercer le président de la
républque mais que son avis soit suivi
ou non gu Carcasson répond toujours
présent chaque fois que les
parlementaires le
sollicitent l'assidé gu dans les
audition parlementairépond
d'abord invité par ces parlementaires
pour venir échanger avec eux et je crois
que là encore c'est le fait que d'une
part il était pas sectaire et écoutit
tous les points de vue et d'autre part
avait cette double connaissance de de
l'acteur et pas du spectateur mais de de
l'homme qui réfléchit sur ces questions
et c'est pour ça qu'il était qu'il était
écouté pas forcément toujours entendu
moi je suis personnellement très
parlementariste j'aime le Parlement J a
passé c'est bizarre hein mais j'ai a
passé beaucoup d'heures dans ma vie pour
tout un tas de raisons et je trouve que
c'est un endroit formidable où il se
passe des tas de choses c'est c'est
passionnant c'est fascinant je suis
favorable à ce que le Parlement est
évidemment un rôle digne de lui un rôle
important mais enfin il y a quand même
des choses dans la vie plus
importantes
que assurer de manière radicale la
revalorisation du Parlement vous avez
entendu comme moi la radio hier que on
avait découvert un monsieur qui avait 11
g d'alcool dans le sang et je pense que
la France a 11 g de norme dans le
sang et que toutes les capacités
d'absorption rationnelle sont largement
dépassé que n'importe quel autre pays
aurait déjà fait un ictus ou une
apoplexie et que chez nous on a
l'impression qu'on continue à pouvoir en
déverser comme ça voilà
59 début de la 5e République et voilà
les lois voté aujourd'hui 1400 pages
contre 260 il il y a 46 ans cette folie
législative éme aus législateurs
eux-mêmes dans le silence de la
bibliothèque de leur grande maison tous
ou presque à quièe et se Gause de
l'ineeptiie de certaines lois comme
celle-ci reconnaissant l'existence des
montagnes en France le premier à
ridiculisé certains textes et le
président de l'Assemblée nationale en
personne Jean-Louis Debray quand vous
avez dans une loi le directeur dirige où
il est interdit de vendre des boissons
dans les cours des colle quel est le
sens républicain de ces lois j'avais
écrit il y a quelques années que tout
sujet du 20ur fait virtuellement une loi
hélas ça ça se confirme quotidiennement
quoi qu'écrive le législateur un chien
méchant continuera à mordre et un enfant
pourra toujours se noyer dans une
piscine de même qu'un ascenseur pourra
tomber mais mais on fait une loi parce
qu'on se dit que sinon on pourrait se
faire reprocher de ne pas l'avoir faite
que qu'a fait le législateur qu'a fait
le législateur donc on présuppose qu'il
y a de la part de l'opinion publique une
espèce de revendication législative
pre et permanente que à ma connaissance
personne ne s'est jamais préoccupé de
vérifier et finalement ce que vous êtes
en train de m'expliquer ce que disait
monsieur Gor c'est que vous vous
apprêtez à faire une loi médiatique une
loi communicationnelle si si si si si si
j'ai le sentiment qu'il s'agit là d'une
législation qui est beaucoup moins
rendue nécessaire par le constat
objectif d'une situation que par le
souci de compl de l' de temps à ce que
l'on croit être l'état de l'opinion ou
de sacrifier à l'air du temps et je suis
désolé de dire que me semble-t-il ce
n'est pas ains que on fait de la bonne
législation sa grande préoccupation je
dirais même saette façon son angoisse
c'était que les universitaires puissent
un jour ne plus être
sollicité que les universitaires
puissent ne plus être sollicités pour
éclairer euh le débat public mais
politiques et médias sont
incorrigibles quand la polémique
s'installe au risque d'exacerber les
tensions gu Carcasson déplace le sujet
sur le terrain du droit pour légiférer
sans
diviser le législateur est parfaitement
fondé à considérer que la dissimulation
intégrale du visage est en elle-même un
trouble à l'ordre public parce que nous
vivons dans une société dans laquelle on
montre son visage dans laquelle on
communique en s'identifiant les uns et
les autres on reconnaissait que les
adversaires d'une loi interdisant la
burka ne contestent pas les principes de
cette loi mais l'effet qu'elle pourrait
produire sur la communauté visée c'est
un problème de de d'opportunité et de
d'effet sur une communauté c'est
précisément la raison pour laquelle je
suis extrêmement sensible au fondement
sur lequel cette interdiction devrait
être décidée s'il s'agit de l'ordre et
du crédit public et si comme je le
suggère cela concerne toute
dissimulation du visage ce n'est pas une
mesure contre une religion le
gouvernement n'est pas de cet avis c'est
au nom de la dignité de la femme qu'il
faut interdire le voile intégral de quoi
inspirer Agy Carcasson une de ses
pldoiries les plus fameuses sur la
défense des libertés individuelles
est-ce que vous pensez monsieur
Carcasson qu'il serait possible de
fonder une éventuelle interdiction du
por du voile intégral dans l'espace
public sur la notion de dignité de la
personne humaine comm une composante de
l'ordre public imaginez imaginez dans
quelle situation invraisemblablement
oiseuse nous nous trouverions aussitôt
si l'on prétendait interdire le voile
intégral au nom de la dignité ah mais ça
on va adresser un stimulus
extraordinaire à toutes les ligues de
vertus en tout genre qui vont commencer
à à tempéter ah bon le nikab on peut
interdire au nom de l'atteinte à la
dignité de la personne humaine mais il
faut tout de suite interdire la
pornographie il faut tout de suite
interdire la prostitution tant qu'on y
est il faut tout de suite interdire le
piercing tout ça sont des sont des des
des des des comportements des choses qui
sont notoirement évidemment attentatoire
à la dignité de la personne humaine
particulièrement à la dignité des femmes
donc on pénètre là sur un terrain
extraordinairement
marécageux on ne peut pas on ne doit pas
et il n'y a surtout aucune raison de
faire entrer en conflit la dignité et la
liberté nul n'est juge de ma dignité je
suis le seul juge de ma dignité et
j'entends bien interdire à quiconque
fusce malgré tout le respect que j'ai à
son égard au législateur lui-même de me
dire ce qui est digne de moi et ce qui
n'est pas digne de moi en tant que
membre de l'espèce humaine ça c'est la
question non ce n'est pas la casistique
monsieur le député une fois encore
l'origine de la dignité l'origine de la
dignité que vous le vouliez ou non n'a
jamais eu comme objectif d'armer le
législateur pour l'autoriser à décider
de ce qu'il veut je ne parle pas du
législateur démocratique et républicain
que vous êtes tous mais on sait très
bien que le législateur peut nêtre pas
démocratique et pas républicain et je
considère d'ailleurs qu'il commence à
cesser d'être démocratique à l'instant
où il décide de se
superposer à la liberté pour souscouvert
de dignité dire aux gens ce qu'il
doivent faire ou ce qu'ils ne doivent
pas faire la liberté reste
première il avait le goût du combat des
idées donc si une idée n'était pas la
sienne il avait envie de la la contester
mais non il était pas Rud je dirais
plutôt que de de son métier de
professeur il avait gardé l'envie de
d'être pédagogue de transmettre toujours
un un en même temps qu'un plaisir que
d'être auditionné par la commission des
lois et je suis professeur à Paris
d'entaire où d'ailleurs je fais cours
dans 50 minutes donc ce qui expliquera
le fait que je vous demande de me le
pardonner par avance mais à 11h30 au
plus tard il faudra que je saute sur mon
scooter pour ne pas faire trop attendre
mes étudiants mais mais ils comprendront
que le mon retard exceptionnel sera dû à
la bonne
cause les étudiants toujours les
étudiants c'était bien là sa priorité en
toute
circonstances à sa prodction quoi de
plus naturel pour celui qui de Paris à
Kabou de l'Assemblée nationale à
Matignon de la collectivité de Corse au
Conseil constitutionnel n'aura eu de
sess pendant 40 ans de se présenter
ainsi je m'appelle Guy Carcasson et je
suis professeur de droit à l'université
de
nantherre pas d'autres
questions et bien s'il n'y a pas
d'autres questions il me reste à vous
remercier et à vous souhaiter tout le
succès possible dans vos
études
[Musique]